[Music]
do you guys know about the Putnam it's a
math competition for undergraduate
students it's a six hour long test that
just has 12 questions broken up into two
different three-hour sessions in each
one of those questions is scored one to
ten so the highest possible score would
be 120 and yet despite the fact that the
only students taking this thing each
year are those who clearly are already
pretty interested in math the median
score tends to be around one or two so
it's a hard test and on each one of
those sections of six questions the
problems tend to get harder as you go
from one to six although of course
difficulty is in the eye of the beholder
but the thing about those fives and
sixes is that even though they're
positioned as the hardest problems on a
famously hard test quite often these are
the ones with the most elegant solutions
available some subtle shift in
perspective that transforms it from very
challenging to doable here I'm gonna
share with you one problem that came up
as the sixth question on one of these
tests a while back and those of you who
follow the channel you know that rather
than just jumping straight to the
solution which in this case would be
surprisingly short when possible I like
to take the time to walk you through how
you might have stumbled across the
solution yourself where the insight
comes from that is make a video more
about the problem-solving process than
about the problem used to exemplify it
so anyway here's the question if you
choose four random points on a sphere
and consider the tetrahedron with these
points as its vertices what is the
probability that the center of the
sphere is inside that tetrahedron go
ahead take a moment and kind of digest
this question
you might start thinking about which of
these tetrahedra contain the sphere
Center which ones don't how you might
systematically distinguish the two and
how do you even approach a problem like
this right where do you even start well
it's usually a good idea to think about
simpler cases so let's knock things down
to two dimensions where you'll choose
three random points on a circle and it's
always helpful to name things so let's
call these guys p1 p2 and p3
the question is what's the probability
that the triangle formed by these points
contains the center of the circle I
think you'll agree it's way easier to
visualize now but it's still a hard
question so again you ask is there a way
to simplify what's going on get
ourselves to some kind of foothold that
we can build up from well maybe you
imagine fixing p1 and p2 in place and
only letting that Third Point vary and
when you do this and you play around
with it in your mind you might notice
that there's a special region a certain
arc where when p3 is in that arc the
triangle contains the center otherwise
not specifically if you draw lines from
p1 and p2 through the center these lines
divide up the circle into four different
arcs and if p3 happens to be in the one
on the opposite side as p1 and p2 the
triangle has the center if it's in any
of the other arcs though no luck we're
assuming here that all of the points of
the circle are equally likely so what is
the probability that p3 lands in that
arc it's the length of that arc divided
by the full circumference of the circle
the proportion of the circle that this
arc makes up so what is that proportion
obviously that depends on where you put
the first two points I mean if they're
90 degrees apart from each other then
the relevant arc is one quarter of the
circle but if those two points were
farther apart that proportion would be
something closer to 1/2 and if they were
really close together that proportion
gets closer to zero so think about this
for a moment
p1 and p2 are chosen randomly with every
point on the circle being equally likely
so what is the average size of this
relevant arc
maybe you imagine fixing p1 in place and
just considering all the places that p2
might be all of the possible angles
between these two lines every angle from
zero degrees up to 180 degrees is
equally likely so every proportion
between 0 and 0.5 is equally likely and
that means that the average proportion
is 0.25 so if the average size of this
arc is a quarter of the full circle the
average probability that the Third Point
lands in it is 1/4 and that means that
the overall probability that our
triangle contains the center is 1/4 but
can we extend this into the
three-dimensional case if you imagine
three out of those four points just
being fixed in place which points of the
sphere can the fourth one be on so that
the tetrahedron that they form contain
the center of the sphere just like
before let's go ahead and draw some
lines from each of those fixed three
points through the center of the sphere
and here it's also helpful if we draw
some planes that are determined by any
pair of these lines now what these
planes do you might notice is divide the
sphere into eight different sections
each of which is a sort of spherical
triangle and our tetrahedron is only
going to contain the center of the
sphere if the fourth point is in the
spherical triangle on the opposite side
as the first three now unlike the 2d
case it's pretty difficult to think
about the average size of this section
as we let the initial three points vary
those of you with some multi variable
calculus under your belt might think
let's just try a surface integral and by
all means pull out some paper and give
it a try but it's not easy and of course
it should be difficult I mean this is
the sixth problem on a Putnam what do
you expect and what do you even do with
it well one thing you can do is back up
to the 2-dimensional case and
contemplate if there is a different way
to think about the same answer that we
got that answer one-fourth looks
suspiciously clean and it raises the
question of what that four represents
one of the main reasons I wanted to make
a video about this particular problem is
that what's about to happen
carries with it a broader lesson for
mathematical problem solving think about
those two lines that we drew for P 1 and
P 2 through the origin they made the
problem a lot easier to think about and
in general whenever you've added
something to the problem set up that
makes it conceptually easier see if you
can reframe the entire question in terms
of those things that you just added in
this case rather than thinking about
choosing three points randomly start by
saying choose two random lines that pass
through the circle Center for each line
there's two possible points that it
could correspond to so just flip a coin
for each one to choose which of the end
points is going to be p1 and likewise
for the other which end point is going
to be p2 choosing a random line and
flipping a coin like this is the same
thing as choosing a random point on the
circle it just feels a little bit
convoluted at first but the reason for
thinking about the random process this
way is that things are actually about to
become easier we'll still think about
that third point p3 as just being a
random point on the circle but imagine
that it was chosen before you do the two
coin flips because you see once the two
lines and that third point are set in
stone there's only four possibilities
for where p1 and p2 might end up based
on those coin flips each one being
equally likely but one and only one of
those four outcomes leaves p1 and p2 on
the opposite side of the circle as p3
with the triangle that they form
containing the center so no matter where
those two lines end up and where that p3
ends up it's always a 1/4 chance that
the coin flips leave us with a triangle
containing the center
now that's very subtle just by reframing
how we think about the random process
for choosing points the answer one
quarter popped out in a very different
way from how it did before and
importantly this style of argument
generalizes seamlessly up into three
dimensions again instead of starting off
by picking four random points imagine
choosing three random lines through the
center of the sphere and then some
random point for P for that first line
passes through the sphere at two points
so flip a coin to decide which of those
two points is going to be p1 likewise
for each of the other lines flip a coin
to decide where p2 and p3 end up now
there's a equally likely outcomes of
those coin flips but one and only one of
them is going to place p1 p2 and p3 on
the opposite side of the center as p4 so
one and only one of these eight equally
likely outcomes gives us a tetrahedron
that contains the center again it's kind
of subtle how that pops out to us but
isn't that elegant this is a valid
solution to the problem but admittedly
the way that I've stated it so far rests
on some visual intuition if you're
curious about how you might write it up
in a way that doesn't rely on visual
intuition I've left a link in the
description to one such write-up in the
language of linear algebra if you're
curious and this is pretty common in
math we're having the key insight and
understanding is one thing but having
the relevant background to articulate
that understanding more formally is
almost a separate muscle entirely one
that undergraduate math students can
have spend most of their time building
up but the main takeaway here is not the
solution itself but how you might find
that key insight if it was put in front
of you and you were just left to solve
it namely just keep asking simpler
versions of the question until you can
get some kind of foothold and then when
you do if there's any kind of added
construct that proves to be useful see
if you can reframe the whole question
around that new construct to close
things off here I've got another
probability puzzle one that comes from
this video sponsor brilliant org suppose
that you have eight students sitting in
a circle taking the Putnam it's a hard
test so each student tries to cheat off
of his neighbor choosing randomly which
neighbor to cheat from now circle all of
the students that don't have somebody
cheating off of their test what is the
expected number of such circled students
it's an interesting question right
brilliant org is a site where you can
practice your problem-solving abilities
with questions like this and many many
more and that really is the best way to
learn you're going to find countless
interesting questions curated in a
pretty thoughtful way so that you really
do come away better at problem solving
if you want more probability they have a
really good course on probability but
they've got all sorts of other math and
science as well so you're almost
certainly going to find something that
interests you me I've been a fan for a
while and if you go to brilliant org
slash three b-1b it lets them know that
you came from here and the first 256 of
you to visit that link can get 20% off
their premium membership which is the
one I use if you want to upgrade also if
you're just itching to see a solution to
this puzzle which by the way uses a
certain tactic and probability that's
useful in a lot of other circumstances I
also left a link in the description that
just jumps you straight to the solution
[Music]
you